that's Miley Cyrus and husband Liam  Hemsworth being grabbed at by fans crowd  went nuts for the couple as they exited  their hotel in Spain security guards are  seen jumping into the situation but not  before Miley was forcibly kissed by a  rogue fan liam is seen reaching his arm  around Miley two seemingly protect her  as they head toward a waiting car  getting help these more important than  anything else a source tells ET that the  former Disney star was unsettled by the  incident but is now doing fine  [Music]  the couple was in Barcelona when the  incident went down Miley was there to  perform at Primavera Sound 2019 on  Friday she's currently promoting her new  EP she is coming which dropped the same  day she is coming as the first of three  EPS Cyrus has planned to come out this  year with she is here expected to come  out in the summer she is everything will  drop toward the end of the year